in what what should be
the lead story across the board on all
of the major news networks on every
major newspaper and is not
is that a man was arrested near
supreme court justice brett kavanaugh's
home
not just with a weapon a variety of
weapons
burglar's tools and other items that
implied he not only wanted to kill
assassinate the justice he wanted to
kidnap him
and and do who knows what
this man apparently went to the went was
going to the home of kavanaugh in the
wee hours of the morning
saw a couple marshals and panicked and
then turned himself in
this is insane
and this was a 26 year old man who was
motivated by liberal politics he said
that he was concerned about what might
happen with roe v wade because of the
leaked draft he was concerned about
these mass shootings and uh he said he
wasn't thinking straight
you know it was not that long ago we
talked about a survey that came from the
southern poverty law center that showed
of all the demographics between
republicans and democrats young and old
it was young democrat men
44
favored the idea the idea of
assassinating politicians they thought
were causing harm to to democracy or the
country
and then it's not even a week later
we have this story
and you know what the craziest thing is
the group that doxed the homes of the
justices ruth sent us announced they
will be returning to his home in
violation of the law and merrick garland
has done nothing
so do you blame me when i'm like yeah i
think there's going to be a civil war if
there's not one already started because
you have people breaking the law with no
no consequence and i and this is exactly
what i warned about if you don't set the
boundary you come to the pro you protest
at justice's house we arrest you you get
a slap on the wrist you go on your way
if you don't draw the line there they
escalated and this is exactly what just
happened and once again merrick garland
will not be enforcing the law against
these people who are in clear violation
of it
so i i can only make assumptions as to
what happened so
we'll talk about that we got a bunch of
other stories we got this uh chessup
boudin or haverford kansas name
soros backed d.a in san francisco has
been recalled he's gone people uh they
actually like it when their laws are
enforced san francisco's become a mess
there's poop everywhere there's
shoplifting there's mass raids on stores
and the house just passed what many
people are calling a symbolic gun
control bill that is just absurdly
unconstitutional raising the gun age or
the age to buy a rifle from 18 to 21
which just on its face is a violation of
the second amendment this probably won't
go anywhere i think even mitch mcconnell
said it it's not going to happen
we'll talk about that we gotta talk
about these books in schools because our
guest is actually taking action on this
joining us today is tommy altman hey
thanks for having me man i really
appreciate it do you want to introduce
yourself sure yeah my name's tommy
altman i'm running for congress in the
second district of virginia to my
hometown uh so you know my wife and i
are born and raised there in the
district we grew up in chesapeake and um
and honestly man it's an honor to to run
and work to earn the votes of people
that we grew up with um and it's
honestly it's just been a lot of fun it
really has been um
so yeah it's it's crazy we're seeing a
crazy time in the world right now and uh
you know i just tell people hey man go
go check out our website it's tommy
altman.com if you want more information
um
special operator serving underground
afghanistan and iraq um yeah and so and
now you you got you i think you won what
a couple lawsuits against these these
lewd books yeah so um it's interesting
and so we've come to our attention that
some of these books that are so sexually
explicit in our school libraries
and um you know of course you go to
those school boards and people are
trying to get them taken off the you
know the library books the bookshelves
and
and there's people getting thrown out of
the the the school boards and telling
them you know hey you can't even read
the books in here and everything else
i'm like so finally i was like whoa
i started looking at the
what's the other side that i'll do
they've always been taking us to court
for the longest time and that's how they
win so i said man let's take some action
there's got to be legal action if we
can't go through our elected officials
we have to be able to go through the
judicial process and so
yeah we stood regarding two books uh one
is genderqueer it's the most
controversial book in all the united
states and then the other one is the
court of mist and fury and so one is uh
one's heterosexual one's homosexual in
nature and so this is simply we're all
we're asking for we're not asking to ban
the books we're simply asking for
parental rights to be restored so for
parental consent to be given for minors
to view sexually explicit material we'll
we'll get into all that too that's
really really interesting so so cool
thanks for joining us yeah we also have
luke
hey guys i came here with one very
simple message and uh that is that
inflation is theft and if you agree with
that message uh you could also get this
shirt in many different uh ways on
thebestpoliticoshorts.com there's also a
big discount for members on lucancer.com
thanks for having me this should be a
very good conversation i'm excited to
get into all the craziness that's only
going to be amplifying and getting a lot
more crazy from here you need to like
sneak on that shirt and the fed
somewhere i know i have my like slogan
hidden somewhere but end the flight
definitely is
repeal the federal reserve act there you
go that's one step absolutely last night
was uh it was kind of a rough a rough
psychological night after the show i was
like really kind of thinking like for
the first time the inflation thing was
kind of coming home and i thought yeah
it does feel like 1928 kind of like uh
from a broad scale and like i we got to
make sure we every do everything in our
power not to become like the nazi party
because that didn't happen immediately
it was like a 10-year process of like
going after the other blaming other
people political prisoners taking the
guns it's just
like you're talking about democrats
talking about the le like we should not
come down on the left because that is
what the nazis did they came down on the
other we got to be careful that we do
not start othering people i think you
have it backwards i just whatever
direction it's headed it's the democrats
are trying to seize the guns it's the
democrats who are voting in lockstep i
know it's not it's the it's not an exact
rep
the pass is only a blueprint we just
wanted to tell them to stop being nice
of course of course and we need to live
with the examples so that they follow
our example
i don't know i don't know if there's a
path out of that to be completely honest
man it is terrible besides clashing and
unstoppable force
honestly i mean that's why i'm running i
sure hope there is
otherwise the the only alternative is
violence on the streets yes and so i
mean having which has already been
happening right but well
yeah but i mean it's it's
it's the side that actually uh does not
advocate for violence doesn't like guns
and everything else what i'm really
worried about is are the people that are
comfortable with violence
then taken to the streets that's when
things really would get bad so i mean
having been overseas and seen violence
in the streets in other in other
countries i don't want to say i think a
better way to put it is i think antifa
loves violence i think these these far
left extremists love engaging in it but
they're not good at it no i'm saying
they're not good at it though the issue
is when the warriors actually decide to
come out and that's when things get
crazy but we'll talk about that in this
first second we also have lydia yeah i'm
gonna try to keep us from getting super
filled tonight hopefully it'll be a
great night excited to hear what tommy's
been up to it sounds like a really
positive change i'm looking forward to
it before we get started head over to
timcast.com and become a member to help
support our work as members you get
access to exclusive segments from this
show monday through thursday at 11 p.m
this is the tim cast irl after dark not
family-friendly version of the show
where we say really all we swear a lot
after hours we show things that people
we talked about you know the other night
it was really bad we were like two
nights ago i think we were talking about
the child abuse what's going on with
these drag queen kid things yeah where
there's like a photo of a kid with a
nude adult man like this is the kind of
stuff that um
people need people need to hear but
that's what you that's what your help
you're helping support our work calling
these things out exposing what's going
on and uh you will also be supporting
our infrastructure we work with rumble
because we want to get away from big
tech censorship and become more
resilient and you're supporting our
journalists so head over to timcast.com
sign up don't forget to smash that like
button subscribe to this channel share
the show with your friends let's get
into the first big story breaking news
breaking news from earlier today
armed man who wanted to kill brett
kavanaugh arrested near justice's home
california man was in possession of a
gun and burglary tools
the man 26 year old nicholas john rosk
of simi simi valley california was
carrying a firearm according to fox news
he also had burglary tools the federal
affidavit filed against the would-be
assailant states ross was in possession
of pepper spray zip ties a hammer a
crowbar duct tape and a tactical knife
in addition to a glock 17 pistol with
two magazines and ammunition
sources for the post claimed the man was
angered over a leaked draft of a
february supreme court opinion that
could possibly signal the overturning of
roe v wade they indicated he was also
upset about the recent spate of mass
shootings this is clearly
modern democrat liberal politics
motivating this guy
to try and kill a supreme court justice
i want to show you this
this is the southern poverty law
center's uh poll that came out one week
ago
section four partisanship and violence
total approval for quote assassinating a
politician who is harming the country or
our democracy
shockingly younger republican men one
third of them agree with that
younger democratic men 44 the largest
group support political assassinations
now i know it's bad because we have this
young democrat-minded individual who is
apparently attempt he's charged with
attempted murder that's it charged with
attempted murder
young republican women were at 40
percent right in support of
assassinations and young republican men
at 34 young democrats talking about
earlier
yeah that's that's the other side of the
aisle that's what i'm that's the concern
honestly you know i mean you talk about
violence in the streets
it's probably why young the reason i
would say young republican men are
probably of young the younger
demographic the least likely to support
well they're not young democrat women
were the least likely but i would say
one of the reasons younger republican
men are
lower in support of this is because many
of them may have actually seen violence
many of them veterans absolutely but
that's the thing
it's the younger group
of people you know it's not the older
group so it's the next generation coming
up
that they're so frustrated with our
political system right now that this is
what they believe the alternative is and
it is
if people aren't being heard that is the
alternative for sure it doesn't matter
what's out there oh you're born that's
what you see it all the time those are
revolutions come from another aspect to
understand here is that the younger
generation is more emotionally unstable
is more likely to be in poverty has less
ability for upward uh economic mobility
and s and is being dumped with big
pharma medicines on top of having
not harmonious relationships with
partners so when you add all of that up
you have the perfect recipe for
radicalization because if you look at
what's been happening in the middle east
you see a lot of guys who are not
intelligent iq is also going down here
in the united states that's also a
correlation with violence so it's
poverty so it's relationship status you
see all of those factors going down so
politically we are prepping the next
generation of the youth to be violent
people especially when you look at the
mind control that's happening on big
tech social media that is pushing them
to these radical ideas by censoring free
speech by censoring debate and only
allowing echo chambers to be heard
radicalizing individuals towards their
political opinions even further which is
extremely dangerous and to me this is
all being done deliberately a part of a
divide and conquer agenda so people
fight each other rather than look at the
true culprits of the problems that are
being created for them yep i would agree
with that i talk about a lot actually
one of my favorite days um in my
lifetime is actually september 12 2001
the day after 9 11 when you know we're
still reeling in pain everybody's in
shock uh compare you know because of
what happened
but in that time the images that were
coming out people were covered in ashes
from the towers and everything doesn't
matter what color you were it didn't
matter who you voted for in the last
election cycle didn't matter what your
your gender was or what religion you
were an american and we had your back
and that's what we have to get back to
if we don't get back to that
then what are we going to do with the
nation i was there in new york city the
dust went into my neighborhood and i
also you know i think we should be
careful after that we also went into you
know iraq we went to afghanistan we got
ourselves into a mess there was a lot of
cohesion there was a lot of patriot
patriotism but
the political parties inside of the
united states used it for their own
personal advantage helping the
military-industrial complex leading us
astray with our foreign policy creating
a lot of devastating situations that i
think you know we should looking back on
were absolute mistakes that we relied
into so if we could i was there too
actually i lived in there and i remember
hanging out with everybody on the 12th
and sitting out at lunch just talking
and feeling it like making eye contact
with people walking down the street
i want that without the tragedy sure
without the deficit we don't need to
scare people into that but there was a
cohesion there was an energy we're in
this together you know you know my
friends my family were a part of this
and and you looked at your neighbor you
saw someone that was you know a part of
your country because you know the whole
idea was we were attacked we need to
come together so there was a lot of
strength in that moment and there was a
lot of you know amazing things that
could have happened but i just i just
think you know we always got to be all
so careful in those moments as well the
federal reserve system it's a form of
attack inflation is a kind of theft like
you said earlier luke and it's not a
joke yeah it's the largest tax if people
felt that that attack like like
september 11th i think there would be a
lot more of unity uh around it as a
foreign feeling people can only but
people can only understand for the most
the average person only understands
single-layer issues
so they say
why don't i make enough money at my job
or or they say more importantly why
can't i afford to buy gas and what do
you get from the average you know
millennial or particularly millennial
females who vote democrat it's because
i'm not being paid enough by my boss
right that's not the case that's not the
case and so they say we need to raise
the minimum wage and you say okay that's
layer one
what's layer two to that proposal
increasing the minimum wage results in
just generic inflation across the board
and it and it creates only a temporary
relief that doesn't actually solve the
problem yeah but six months
if that's if that
yeah and so you know you try to explain
basic economics to people the the
minimum wage is completely meaningless
yep completely what matters is how much
can you buy for the equivalent of one
hour of labor
so they say well then we should pay more
but that number doesn't mean anything
because when you just make everybody
have to be paid a base rate then the
base base cost of good has to go up
they like to point out like denmark and
they're like well in denmark they pay 20
bucks an hour and a burger's only two
bucks totally different economy value
systems and a different value of labor
per hour than we have you can't solve
cultural problems with policy yeah no i
absolutely agree with you and that's one
of the things that you know being a
small business owner one of the things i
talked to with all my you know staff
about i was talking one of my buddies
and uh when when the minimum wage went
up it was a great idea like well sure
it's a great idea except for now you're
just simply reducing your purchasing
power it's going to happen in time
you're going to have a cycle it's going
to come back around and then very very
soon he was like wait a minute all of
our supplies are way more expensive now
and it took about six months i said yep
and it's going to take you about three
or four years for us to catch up to be
charging again what we had again two
years ago it's also just one thing
really quickly the financial components
are important here but just back to this
kavanaugh story because this is this is
a big story this is something major that
has been building up incrementally uh to
the point where even the department of
homeland security just issued a new memo
saying that there's most likely a very
big chance for more violence this summer
politically because of the midterms
because of the border crisis because of
the supreme court decisions so even
homeland security is warning saying
there's going to be some internal
violence and turmoil happening here in
the united states how do we de-escalate
it when almost every single factor big
tech social media uh the corporate
mainstream media every politician is
adding fuel to the fire how do we stop
you can't
yep i i don't think it's possible maybe
it was possible
six years ago
maybe it wasn't maybe with donald trump
he you know he really broke these people
but that i i believe that you know i've
been i've been covering
i was covering conflict in crisis
at occupy wall street yeah i started
covering it for vice i covered a little
bit when i was working for fusion the
abc news company
and i don't see a path towards bringing
this country together
what i see is
you have uh what i i like to reference
stephen marsh he wrote the book the next
civil war when he said to us that you
have a multicultural democracy and a
constitutional republic in the same in
the same country trying to fight for
control and you can't have both and he's
completely right
i believe in a constitutional republic
you know uh i've tried i grew up
traditionally democrat but the reason
why today people who used to be on the
left like elon musk or joe rogan are
called right-wing is because they still
believe in those values of a
constitutional republic
the left
absolute chaos
you right now you have occupy wall
street activists that i know tweeting in
defense
of telling children it's not going to
lick itself
they have no principles
they have no moral standard other than i
want power fu
one side has no principles one side has
standardized principles and various
disagreements you've got post liberals
libertarians moderates centrists and
conservatives in one side and then you
have the psychotic death cult on the
other side right there was
confrontations there was fighting
outside of that dallas uh venue where
they were doing those sick things with
children there was activists coming
there saying no we're going to fight
anyone who's protesting this this is the
insane level that we reach that's what
we need to understand i want to explain
what i just said psychotic death cult
because i hear it all the time from the
left and msnbc they're like the trump
supporters in the cult let me explain
the q and on people i think they're nuts
i completely disagree with conservative
christians on a lot of moral issues but
we can sit down and talk about the
constitution the founding documents the
rules by which we seek to compromise and
self-govern i can sit here and say i
disagree with you conservative on tax
policy and then we all laugh get along
and tell each other jokes the other side
puts a big neon sign up saying it's not
going to lick itself they fire bomb
buildings that we had the worst riots
we've ever seen and it's all lies and
i'm not just talking about leftists i'm
talking about the mainstream press the
corporate press msnbc had the nerve to
come out and be like what a shocking
story this man had weapons and he was at
kavanaugh's home msnbc advocated for it
they advocated msnbc ran a story saying
it was good that they were going to his
house
these people are absolutely deranged
look when trump comes out and says
something i outright say i think i think
he's wrong he talks about fraud all the
time i'm like nah that guy's wrong and
they call us a cult no i'm telling you
that guy's wrong but they come out on
their own platform and say it's good
we're going to his house then it happens
to go oh heaven's me
they're in a cult they just they prop up
whatever is not the right or whatever is
not america and that extends to the
point where they've lost their minds and
you have adult men
taking dollar bills from children into
bikinis and thongs you have this thing
in dallas where it says it's not going
to lick itself and they're like this is
a good a normal thing and it's
family-friendly and i'm like no you just
have no principles no standards no
morals and all you do is fight for power
for whatever your side is and your side
is basically whatever the other is not
no you're absolutely right they actually
treat it like a faith system
that's what's interesting to me i mean
so
amidst everything else i'm also an
ordained minister so they treat it very
much like a base system they promote it
like one to defend it like one and and
the interesting thing is i mean even
saying liberals anymore i don't think
it's accurate right i really don't i
mean i have friends that that were
liberals five years ago
but they i wouldn't call them a liberal
now they the liberal is gone these
they've been taken over by
radicals this is radical liberalism
the interesting thing that happened is
that you had the the principled liberals
have become what's called disaffected or
post liberal yep and the people who are
just tribalists have become
establishment or leftist right but it's
it's funny because you look at a lot of
these younger leftists they're pro guns
but they keep defending the
establishment and the the psychopathy of
this cult
yeah it's crazy that's why i'm sorry
look
when
i just got to put it this way
when they come out
and they have children on stage at 21
and up gay bars desmond is amazing
ripping off his clothing and being
handed money to do so that's called
stripping yeah and i'm not exaggerating
anybody who knows anything about what
stripping is knows that bikini bars are
fully clothed women dancing on poles and
shaking it for men for cash but they're
wearing clothes when you have a little
boy on stage and he rips his clothes off
for adult gay men who give him money
pedophilia these are pedophiles and the
left overtly defends it and what do you
get in florida when a reasonable
proposal is made maybe parents should
know about this they say you're trying
to ban gay people it's like dude if you
want to defend pedophiles that's on you
but this is why i don't think there's
reconciliation
yeah and maybe not especially for some
of these issues um and i talk a lot
about especially with the campaign how
you think about things on a different
level honestly quite honestly i think
everybody should run for office because
it makes you think about things in a
different level than you ever would have
before um it's really interesting but i
talk a lot about just getting back to
our founding principles of faith family
and freedom like these very basic things
that you know some people call them
trite i think if we don't get back to
the things that made us great to start
with i think we're doomed as a nation
and so some of that i think is
absolutely right i think it ties into
what you're talking about right now well
the crazy thing to me is like you know
policy wise i've always been rather
liberal sure but this day and age not
anymore well it's i'm sorry like we had
a guy on the show as progressive who
said i asked him do you think women
should be able to get an abortion at
nine months and he said it's the woman's
choice and i'm like why kill the baby
you can end the pregnancy by delivering
the baby and let the baby live and just
drop it at a fire department he's like a
woman's choice i'm like
okay there's nothing there but then you
have california that now are trying to
advocate post-term abortion and you've
heard it on the street i've heard people
say in interviews they said well seven
days after birth you know
if a woman decides to give up on the
life of her child should she be charged
like you mean murder a child
in in virginia so so do you remember
this in virginia i think it was kathy
tran was her name she she proposed a
bill a no restriction abortion yep and
she was asked i think was by a judge he
said if a woman is dilating at the point
of birth could you abort the baby and
she said there would be no restrictions
it's disgusting that's in virginia it's
evil i mean it really is evil i mean
every society throughout human history
has known that you have to protect the
innocence of children every society and
now we are all of a sudden very quickly
in our society okay with removing the
innocence of children i mean that goes
back to the books you know for me it
goes back to what you're seeing at the
strip clubs you know with all these with
i mean it's you're normalizing
pedophilia let's talk about the book
thing so you know we've seen all this
stuff we have a story here from fox news
texas lawmaker planning bill to ban
children from drag shows not appropriate
at all a lot of this is in a similar
vein where for some reason there's a big
push from the left to expose children to
overtly sexualized activities or overtly
sexual activity you had a lawsuit um was
it just one or were there two so it's
combined into two there's two different
books that are in this lawsuit you
basically uh
you didn't get him banned no parent or
consent is now required to display
sexual contact that's what we're seeking
yeah so okay in virginia you're able to
uh take a book before judge um it's it's
a law a year but take a book for judge
and make see if it's obscene so you get
a ruling on it the judge agreed with us
uh my attorney tell uh delegate tim
anderson and i uh decided you know to
take these books there's two of them
it's the genderqueer again the most
controversial book in the country and
then court of mist and fury and we took
him before a judge and she ruled the
interesting thing is every single judge
in virginia beach recused themselves wow
said it's political nightmare they don't
know it i'm sorry guys
you know i talk about civil war conflict
we have a guy who just got arrested for
attempted murder of justice and i and i
say i don't think there's a way out of
this when the judges are like i'm scared
and too cowardly to stand up for values
and the only thing i can see is their
weak men will lead two hard times oh
absolutely always i mean that's what
we're seeing right now quite honestly i
mean whether it doesn't matter what's on
the island you've had some weak
politicians for a long time this book
genderqueer
has
writing some of the writing in it is
overtly sexualized saying i want your in
my and then you have a photograph of two
people performing acts on each other yep
there's actually two different images of
of activities being performed on each
other adult activities this other book
what was it called court of mist and
fury so what i've not heard this one
though so what's what's so it's actually
it's a it's one of a series uh it's a
three-part series and it's actually
heterosexual nature but the descriptions
of the act of sex
is so descript i mean they can't read so
the local news channel their fm 99
wouldn't wasn't even allowed to read it
on the air was it fcc violation yep
absolutely i know the lady that was
presenting it she's great she was like
well i can't read this and so the other
dj's like well let me i'll read it and
look there you go i can't read this one
there wow but it's okay for sixth
graders to have it 10 to 12 years old
it's okay to give it to our children and
what are they writing these these uh
establishment leftists and liberals are
writing republicans are banning books
i'm a nazi now if you're a book banner
if you believe that you're in a cult i'm
sorry like we don't allow playboy in
schools and playboy isn't like hardcore
stuff right it's you know pinup models
nude women but that's not allowed well
there's got to be a line that's my
that's my point is there has to be a
line
you clearly what for virginia beach
anyway
that school district obviously doesn't
have a clear enough line and i don't
know who it is whoever the failure is
where the breakdown is in administration
and the administrative level level but
whoever it is doesn't have a clear line
so i'm simply asking for parental rights
to be restored so parental consent for
minors to view sexually explicit
material just like when you go to a
movie theater i think one of the issues
is that the whole identity of democrats
is we hate republicans
it started partly with trump i think it
existed a little bit before
but
they said republicans are all bad trump
wins trump is a nazi and now they have
no choice but to stake their identity on
opposing whatever it is that's
right-winged especially if you call
yourself a conservative republican
oh i mean you guys are deserving
republicans are just yeah
he's a borderline socialist and they
call him right wing because they have
every part of their identity must be in
opposition to whatever it is
maybe the good news is there won't be a
major conflict between factions because
they will ostracize themselves to the
point where there's 10 people who hold
their views
one can only hope right but honestly so
i i actually believe thank you so much
for doing what you're doing honestly i
think this is a step in the right
direction it's going to be explaining on
the internet no it's good but this is
this is where noose is now noose is no
longer you know fox news or cnn or msnbc
everybody looks at that and realizes
propaganda you had a chinese
friend who told me said we don't watch
the news in china because we know it's
propaganda for some reason you americans
haven't figured it out yet well i heard
that even fox news was pro gun control
they're all pro gun control yeah they're
that i think someone mentioned in super
chips that on the five they were in
favor of red flag laws nope
right anybody who pays attention knows
red flag laws just mean a violation of
your fourth amendment rights right
that's it well at one time in the va
they wanted to be able to strip you of
of your gun rights if they thought you
had ptsd right so i don't trust anybody
to be able to tell somebody else what
their mental capacity is i mean we do
that before a judge right but not some
doctor we have no idea what these
doctors are doing i think it's a cra
it's a very dangerous way to go down for
me listen i and when i say that you
certainly run for office people
automatically want to go oh well what
about the kids and everything else
that's happened it's a tragedy these
tragedies are horrible and you know i
think i think all americans are
heartbreaks when we see this loss of
innocent life especially so young they
don't care about kids they don't care no
they don't care at all
there's a great meme i love it it said
it was uh the drake meme you know the
one was putting the hand up and he's
like no and the one was like yes and it
says school shootings he was like oh and
then it says school bombings and he's
like right under obama and uh
vice president biden
we had kids being blown up they don't
care right what they care about is
they've got a wedge issue because these
are things like this happen all the time
now they're like look at the mass
shootings in chicago and minnesota
you never care about this stuff they
need a wedge issue for the midterms and
so they're acting like they care about
kids but i'll throw it back to what's
going on with these kids in texas
you got a rep in texas and a rep in
florida want to make drag shows illegal
with minors present the funny thing is
it already is
i don't understand how but the cops
won't do anything right these are these
are adult men in in in sexualized
outfits doing sexualized dances with a
big neon sign reading it's not going to
lick itself and the kids are handing
them money for them to dance right there
i'm like okay that's clearly over the
line right then you had desmond is
amazing little boy dancing on stage
stripping his clothes off as gay as
adult gay men are handing him money and
then you have another kid who's called
queen lactasia
who was posing with a 99
nude man it's a man who's basically but
a tiny little fabric on his junk and the
little boy's touching like touching his
arm and smiling for the camera
they're they're outright targeting and
abusing kids
and then they're acting like they care
about them and no one else does you know
it's funny because when i talk to people
now um you know tell me look we hear the
word conservative a lot
but nobody defines why why am i
conservative and i tell people all the
time look i'm a conservative because i
believe there is a transcendent moral
code there's a right and a wrong there's
a good and evil and i just have seen
evil sweep across this nation for far
too long unchecked and this is what
we're seeing this is the culmination of
it that's that's truly evil
what you're seeing with these kids and
anybody who thinks otherwise is i think
you're just sick honestly
have you seen the documentary what is a
woman the daily i have not seen it i've
seen parts of it and seen the whole
thing and it is really good it's great
they the daily wire just put out some
clips of um they did an audience
screening what do they call it what are
they what do they call it there's like
man i can't think of a focus group focus
group there you go thank you uh and it
was fascinating to see the shock in
regular people's faces when they were
watching this stuff but there was like
one woman she was she was like there's
more than two genders and and the entire
room goes what
like what are you talking about
i think what's happening is
you've got a lot of people who have
their their whole identity is based on
opposing whatever the right is and they
live in a media bubble right like you
mentioned msnbc cnn fox news
so they hear these things and they say
okay they think they're the norm they
think they're normal but they're weird
outliers that represent like eight
percent of the population and it's not
just a media bubble it's a social media
oh yeah with algorithms regurgitating of
political views amplifying them where
people only hear each other and then the
main kind of disagreement that they may
have online is that someone isn't
fighting the other side too hard or is
too sympathetic to the other side and
when you have that kind of environment
you're going to of course reap a lot of
social chaos and i think a lot of this
is being done deliberately because just
even a few years ago i remember doing
independent media almost 15 years ago
and it wasn't like this this political
divide wasn't like this there was a lot
more people in the middle there was a
lot more moderates there was a lot more
people that were able to see common
ground between the left and the right it
wasn't as hyperbolic as insane as crazy
as it is now where you literally have
people
arguing for the abuse of children i mean
it's just so mind-boggling to see so so
it was not that long ago yeah it was not
that long ago i remember it and and you
know i remember even two two and a half
years ago the first time i came on this
show the first thing i said we need a
peaceful divorce and and the
conversation when i brought it up wasn't
even taken seriously he was like yeah
yeah whatever whatever but i was like no
seriously we need a peaceful divorce
because there is no other way to avoid
this larger clash that the ruling elites
are kind of building up so we fight each
other we need we need to stop this
immediately we're going into very
dangerous territory and all the
ingredients all the fuel is being added
to this fire and it's and it's getting
one way you can do that though and i
think roe v wade is a perfect example is
you start you start decentralizing the
federal government reducing federal
government pushing that power back down
to the states people get 50 options
they're going to start migrating to
whatever area they actually decentralize
but that is just geographic polarization
sure what happens if roe v roe and casey
are overturned republicans win a
majority they win the white house and
then do a federal ban on on abortion
i think it's going to be very impressive
so here's here's what i what i'll say to
both of you guys reading the history of
the civil war what did we see the first
thing that happened was a peaceful
divorce sure before abraham lincoln was
inaugurated seven states said we hereby
secede and that was it months went by
with nothing they were like that's it
we're done and then abraham lincoln gets
in and he goes i don't i don't recognize
that as being legitimate
fort sumter in south carolina he's got
occupying forces and the states are all
of them are basically like dude you
can't be here right the fight breaks out
and even after the battle of fort sumter
i think it was uh i think it was lee i'm
not sure they didn't know if it was
actually the start of a civil war or
just some small skirmish and that would
be the end of it sure but because of the
actions by the federal government
several other states were like yo
this is crazy crazy what are you doing
and they backed out ended up joining the
confederacy west virginia virginia
splits into two different states so the
other issue is when it comes to the
geographic hyperpolarization as you
described it tommy
the south was angry because laws were
passed the fugitive slave act right that
if slaves escaped to the north the north
had to return them that was federal law
but they didn't the north said no right
now here's here's the issue i think the
north was right not to do it sure i
think slavery was was completely wrong
in amoral it needed to be ended yeah the
north many in the north were willing to
fight that fight but because of this
southern state said if the law will not
be respected there is no agreement
between us and you right we leave and
that's what precipitated the secession
sure
which ultimately leads to a fight over
weapons which leads to a fight so i i
fear
i said this last year
if
roe v wade if and roe and casey are
overturned
the republicans
then campaign on
banning abortion federally many think
they won't because republicans are more
states rights but let's say they do
they they they win in november we're
five months out but they can't get past
a filibuster and they won't be able to
get past veto sure then donald trump
campaigns and says the first thing i'm
going to do is i'm going to sign the
bill the save the children act and then
he does right then you then you get a
supreme court that is conservative you
get congress and the senate and the
executive branch the bill hits trump's
desks day one he signs it
then you get blue states california
illinois new york who refuse to shut
down abortion clinics
what happens then
will trump send in federal authorities
to do it
will you then get states saying we will
not recognize federal law enforcement
will it result in conflict over these
clinics i'd be willing to bet antifa and
other left-wing groups would show up oh
sure fight with federal authorities at
abortion clinics i'm not saying it will
happen i'm not saying it's like yeah i
think that's the i mean i think that's
the most extreme case obviously but
if you took that power and you push it
back down to states where i think it
belongs
i think our forefathers would say that
kind of power belongs to the state not
the federal level the federal level the
federal government has just become this
all-consuming beast that thinks that and
and people the vast majority of
americans go well let's just let the
government legislate why they've done a
poor very poor job of it why are we
going to trust that we push that power
back down as low as possible to the
states or local localities and that's
where we had the most say that's always
what i'm an advocate for i i do agree i
think
it may be the only option we have so i
was asked by this progressive what i
thought about roe v wade and i'm like
i'm pro-choice
but i think at this point the best thing
we can do is let states be states sure
conservatives can go to red states and
then blue states can go to blue you know
blue people go to blue states or
whatever my answer's the same except i'm
pro-life and i think you should be down
to the states you know i'd still be look
i believe that life begins at conception
so i would always you know seek to push
the needle in that direction however i
think it's a state rights issue i don't
think it's a federal issue i really
don't and i've had people go oh you're
just you're pushing you're passing the
buck i'm like i'm not passing that but
i'm giving you 50 options i think it's
the safest it's the nicest thing to do
most compassionate thing that we do to
people give them 50 options yeah i think
what we're talking about is just
decentralization yeah absolutely and i
think the more we allow individuals to
make the right decisions for themselves
the more we win whenever we have a big
bureaucratic government we have a
government that of course rules for the
many and makes many mistakes right um
and i think that's exactly what we have
right now we have way too much money
invested in it we have way too much
policies we have way too many decisions
being made by this bureaucratic becky
force that doesn't give a damn about the
average person and is serving the needs
of the special ruling class and helping
them out i promise the ruling class too
i mean let's be honest i mean it's we're
supposed to be a constitutional
republican instead where we've become
this you've got this weird opportunity
going on technocratic
corporacy uh run by bankers and shadowy
elites a lot of c's but yeah
you know what it feels like it feels
like you know wealth only lasts a few
generations they say three generations
and it feels like the ruling elites the
the politicians the the the the wealthy
kids they're not good at running these
institutions and organizations
so you look at everything and you're
like why does it feel like these things
are falling apart it's like oh we used
to have oligarchs and ruling elites and
barons
their their great grandkids have no idea
how to run this stuff and it's all just
collapsing around them right no you're
absolutely right i mean but it's it's a
problem when you have these congressmen
and congresswomen going into congress
not worth anything and then four years
later worth 10 million dollars that's a
problem
where did you get that from i know what
your budget was i don't know what your
salary was and there's no way even if
you didn't spend a single jenny just
just i guess people are saying you got
to invest where nancy pelosi invests
because she knows something hey i said
you know you know how to be the the uh
the most favorite congressman in all of
the nation every single one every single
week just say hey these are my
investment opportunities
yeah
we got a bunch of bills on our desk
here's how they're going to vote on them
here's what i'm about here's what i'm
investigating you got to say that hey
this is what i'm investing in yeah there
was entire tick tock channels just built
on what nancy pelosi was trading in the
stock market that got censored and
deleted and taken down well listen i
mean it's criminal you know i mean
absolutely
martha stewart went to jail for it come
on you know i mean if martha stewart can
go to jail for what are we doing here
but we do have to i think we just have
to elect the right people i really do
well let me let me pull this story here
i think there's some some uh some good
news some um positive i want to be all
negative check check this out democrat
turned trump republican wins landslide
victory people don't want biden's
dysfunctional america that's the jeff
van drew slammed biden as the worst
president in american history he's
correct
and what did he get 85 percent of the
vote
you know what this means
this is a moderate yeah he was a
democrat
now he's like the democratic party's
nuts i'm run a republican and 85 percent
of the vote because people
they don't want political extremes the
left wants to paint the right is
extremist no this proves right here
overwhelmingly regular people are just
saying enough to the crazy the good news
here is now this is a primary this is a
guy who ran as a democrat the first time
you take a look at the story we have
from the new york times a georgia
mystery how many democrats voted in the
gop primary a lot of people are saying
democrats are voting in republican
primaries to sabotage trump well the new
york times says actually these people
are swing voters right swing voters are
moving over in large numbers to the
republican party
democrats are quitting and joining
republicans but you have a large group
of swing voters moving over
i think what's happening is
if the democrats whole identity is just
we oppose the republicans right if the
best thing they have to offer us is
culture war and january 6.
while regular people are spending five
bucks a gallon on gas they're just gonna
be like i'm gonna vote for the guys
talking about gas yes that's it you're
100 right you know we just had a uh our
candidate candidate forum uh last night
and that's what i talked about over and
over again so look at it all the rest of
these things really don't matter at the
end of the day the average american is
pissed off that we're having to decide
whether or not we're putting gas in the
car or buying food for our kids that's
what we're mad about and you can't get
baby formula as it is so that one's out
yeah we're going to rely on european
nations to provide american families a
baby formula wow that's a bit of a
problem yeah so here's what i think i
think what we're seeing with this trend
the shift from democrats not all of them
i think what may end up happening is it
republicans
they're saying you know cnn said 80-year
high for republican polling right if
they're up 2.5 they're actually up 10.
yeah
so i think it's possible
come november
we actually see that all of this
psychotic behavior from democrats and
failed economic policy exposes the
emperor having no clothes
these these people on the left who think
they're in the majority who think it's a
horrible pitcher by the way oh right
emperor's biden come on
but these people on the left they think
they're the normal they think they are
mainstream they're not and jeff van dru
proves it yep so i think they're going
to get a rude awakening come in november
something that a reckoning they should
have gotten a long time ago yeah it's
one of the things that actually i'm
actually most frustrated with uh with
the republican party because i keep
telling people like man you know listen
times of chaos are great opportunities
for advancement this is the most chaotic
time in our nation's history we get to
be able to recognize them and be brave
enough to step into them
i think this is an opportunity for the
republican party not just to get the
majority but to get the super majority
this is a great opportunity for him and
i believe that we're letting that slip
away unknowingly because we're just
focusing on the majority because i do
believe i believe that the the
the liberals that
can't say the democrats anymore but you
know these radicals every time they get
into office they pull the needle as far
to the left as they can at this point
they've snapped it off and jumped over a
cliff they've left most of their base
standing on top of the platform going
what's going on they don't have a home
anymore well now a lot of people are
asking themselves if the republicans do
win which it looks like they're going to
win are they going to be sitting on
their hands like they usually do that's
it or will they be able to party and do
something uh
what do you think is going to happen
from from your kind of uh you know
perspective on the ground being a part
of this situation do you think they're
going to be the same kind of lame duck
republicans or do you think they'll be
able to achieve something to do
something it it matters what type of
republican you elect
that's the god's honest church how does
the picture look for you
personally there's there's like ron paul
republicans there's mitt romney
republicans right there's a big spectrum
there i'm certainly not mid
that guy that guy there's trump
republicans um there is no but honestly
i i for me it's about the people i i am
a we the people republican that's who i
am i want to put the people first that i
believe that the republican party is the
party of of hope and opportunity
opportunity i really do believe that
um but we have to do the hard work and i
really believe it's hard work people say
it all the time like oh yo all you talk
about is hard work like that's the
reality it is hard work but it's
supposed to be hard work that's the
thing that i believe that americans
value and so i want to represent the
people more than anything else even more
than a party the people of my district
because that's where i'm born and raised
so i care deeply for the people of our
district and so i want to make sure that
the working class is represented again
because most of us do not feel that
we're represented any longer up in
washington dc
and we make up the majority of america
the working class does so what do you
think is is likely to be achieved
by what could be done yeah well honestly
man we can do the hard work and actually
get our economy back on track
if if biden actually do you think
there's reversing the the secret federal
reserve bailouts the the huge debt we're
in that's going to take decades i mean
yeah honestly i mean there's no way
around no not even a decade
it's impossible to to pay off the debt i
mean you can trillions of dollars no you
can't but you have to do you so look as
a small business owner i took a loan out
for 35 000 to open up my business they
give you five years to pay it off we
paid it off in two because we had a line
item in the budget so create a budget
put a line item in there and then you
cut the fed everywhere else to be able
to pay that off that's what you have to
do there's a lot of money that comes
into the federal government we can't but
we can dissolve some departments like
the department of education department
of energy these departments don't do
anything how about we start doing some
hard work it is hard work to do that
people aren't going to like it you've
got to be able to take the hits and the
other side to be able to tell you that
you're a nazi and you look in the face
like no i'm not i'm doing the hard work
to put the people first again the
problem with federal reserve debt is
when we borrow a million from the
federal reserve the american government
takes out a promissory note we we owe
them back a million plus interest so we
owe them more money than we borrowed
which makes it literally impossible to
pay back at least to pay back the
interest we could pay back the principal
maybe right um do you support defaulting
on the debt on the or at least on the
interest to the federal reserve
yeah
that's not a very hard one i mean
i think i think that i think that's a
hard one i mean i don't
grinding the whole system sure but i
mean quite honestly that system sucks
anyway i know that you know you know
you're right you're right but but it is
hard work you gotta you can't just go in
there and do it you can't just rip the
band-aid off i mean for crying out loud
like how many people have probably lost
their life trying to do that yeah if
we're gonna rip a bandage off we better
have another bandage in our other hand
with ready to put pressure right you
know
literally uh yesterday talked about oh
just just dissolve the the irs well you
can't just you can't just dissolve the
irs you can't just make it go away you
see this
this is a this is a pre-federal reserve
10 bill from the state of georgia bank
of columbus
before the federal reserve you had money
right and people would buy something
backed by a bank with gold in the
reserves and so you could go to new york
with this and they'd be like oh
great
it's a banknote it has value if i need
to and so they traded it like any other
currency right the federal reserve is
just is was just put in place so they
could manipulate and control yep
and it's not just here
it's internationally oh yeah the bank
for international settlements
switzerland so i mean it's these are
the funny thing is that i think that
most of most of us americans until we
really start you know doing some deep
dives into these topics we think it's a
pretty simple answer then we start
looking at it we're like oh no it's not
go back to gun control right so
everybody starts going well let's let
legislators you know make new
legislation that's going to make us safe
no it's not if legislation made us safe
none of these children would be dead
right now because it was illegal for
that guy to walk inside the school and
shoot the kids both of those things are
illegal shooting the kid is illegal and
going inside the school with a gun is
illegal there's got to be some kind of
grand conspiracy going on because we put
up signs saying gun-free zones yeah how
could he have walked past that you must
need bigger signs there there's got to
be something going on because there's no
way to explain how someone could walk
past a sign like that with a gun well
here's the frustrating thing too because
people go oh you're making light of it
so you don't care about these kids
right which is intellectually dishonest
the problem is we cannot use tragic we
can never allow ourselves
to let tragedy dictate policy because if
we do that what's to stop somebody from
creating said tragedy to strip you of
whatever rights or freedoms they want to
know that's what we're doing
let me just
when the reichstag burned in germany
hitler used that as an opportunity to
seize people's civil rights but so just
keeping it on the federal reserve stuff
i think it's fascinating because
a lot of people running for office would
would be too scared to even talk about
the problems of the federal reserve the
manipulation of interest rates
quantitative easing look man never
thought i'd be running for office i mean
look at me my hands are tattooed for
crying out loud i never thought i'd be
running for office i'm running for
office because i'm sick and tired of
what i've seen yeah you know i'm running
for office for for my sons our next
generation
you know i i fought twice for this
country overseas i thought i was one of
the first ones in afghanistan and iraq i
turned 22 two days before we went into
iraq for in kuwait i was a tenth vehicle
to cross the burn from quite into iraq i
saw firsthand what it looks like for
people not to have the same freedoms the
same rights we have guaranteed to us
here it makes all the difference in the
world i had a grown man fall on his
knees in front of me through a
translator tell me why did you guys
leave and he's talking about the gulf
war he said if you hadn't left i
wouldn't have to watch my wife and
sister be raped and killed by saddam's
sons
those guys were brutal right so that's
what is people are capable that's what
human beings are capable of we have so
many freedoms and rights that guarantee
our safety and protection here that's
what i want to see continue i have sons
i don't see violence on the street i
believe that this is the next cycle or
two is maybe the last opportunity that
we have not to see violence on the
streets and that's desperately what i
want i do not want to see americans
killing americans but i want to see our
next generation be free men and women
because that's their birthright it's
like people want the federal government
to protect our rights but we have to
protect our own rights we are the
federal government the government what
about the military like who's in charge
of the military well first off i believe
that our rights are god-given and the
government did by the constitution the
government only infringes your rights
right but they also command the military
it's like joe biden's in control of the
military not in control but he's in
command of the military i don't know
that joe biden control much let's be
honest
he's technically the commander of the
military sure no which is uh very scary
disgusting
look at afghanistan yeah i mean
afghanistan is such a debacle it was a
surrender iraq was it
it showed all signs of a military
surrender not a withdrawal i mean we
know how to withdraw tactically
withdrawal from an area
they did not tactically withdraw not
only that so it showed all signs of
surrender not only that the real problem
is when you're in a conflict and
both sides have to agree that conflict's
over when one side just pretty much says
you know what we give up we're going
home and the other side hasn't hasn't
agreed that the conflict's over the
conflict's not over and now these
terrorists who have chanted death to
america for generations and now we've
enriched them with 85 billion dollars of
our war fighting equipment well it's
going to kill america we have a history
of doing this so sure the 80s and the
muha
and the iraq iran or there's a long
history of especially covert operations
given them with our tax dollars all the
weaponry that they have which is
absolutely insane that they've been
doing this i mean we've trained saddam
they trained obama i mean or uh obama
what kind of the same thing was involved
in the cocaine smuggling or something
yep
specifically there's there's a movie
called american made that actually even
implicates bill clinton uh
in arkansas when he was the governor of
arkansas yes lots of crazy story tom
cruise played a great movie the the
movie still watered down american made
great movie with tom cruise just just
gives you a little point of view but but
waters down the larger scandal that
happened with iran contra that that
again
drug smuggling cocaine smuggling arming
rebels inside of latin america uh arming
the iranians and of course moving on
weapons and and overthrowing governments
all done by the cia while of course
introducing crack cocaine into poor
communities which could be some serious
oversight in yeah you know it's funny
no no no it's not we never got oversight
what we got is fox news contracts for
some of the people who are involved in
that thing which is absolutely
disgusting yeah no
michael malus's quote was fantastic he
said all i'm all i'm asking for is the
right to the same weapons i paid for the
taliban to have yeah right and my
responsibility that's a great quote all
i'm saying is i want to write to the
same weapons we paid for the cartels to
have yes thanks obama
now they're driving through our streets
because the border's wide open yeah it's
amazing
that's crazy there's video of of
cartel members with 50 caliber rifles
driving through the streets in texas
cool wow that's like you need the police
to defend you well you don't you just
need defense and so the police but the
police aren't there the people have to
form militias to defend themselves and
then i'm concerned that the federal
government's going to be like no you're
a terrorist organization trying to
defend yourself well let the cartels
roam free in mexico there's entire
cities like tehran with tens of
thousands of people that that have
defended themselves from the cartels and
when you look at some of the most severe
cartels they have connections to of
course us intelligence agencies that
have trained them there was a mexican
secret police that was trained by u.s
special forces uh that literally was one
of the worst that turned into one of the
worst mexican drug cartels out there uh
in in all of mexico that started to do
all these horrible brutal things so
there's a long history of of just
involvement by government forces making
the situation that much worse uh when
they were previously harmonious is that
because they want to weak mexico so that
we can dominate the border well there's
a lot of corruption inside of mexico and
a lot of politicians willing to look the
other way uh and of course with with the
corrupt government uh you of course have
you know a lot of criminals who are
using government for their own personal
benefit because the politicians are the
true criminals uh down in that country
we got to pull up this story this is big
this is i mean
this is stupid probably not going to go
anywhere but nbc news reports house
votes to raise minimum age to buy
semi-auto automatic rifles at 21. the
provision is poised to be included in a
larger legislative package set for a
final house vote wednesday night so i i
think that's what they did already
didn't they or is this uh okay so this
is what was what was passed right it's
not it's not just
the uh raising the age of 1921 which is
so insanely unconstitutional there's no
way that that survives but it also
addresses 3d printed guns the tracking
of untraceable guns
is something going on
hot action i don't know
we talked we did talk about the fed so
oh
so
something's going on
it's always whenever luke is here so go
check it out
yeah i'll make sure everything's okay
you guys can see first time we got
squatted luke was talking and then like
the police just come in look i'm gonna
be so pissed off i gotta spend the night
in jail tonight
so so we have this article we're talking
about the uh the bill hey by the way
real fast uh my buddy uh joshua carlton
texted me that he's watching he said he
loves you so oh cool appreciate that
josh it's pretty serious what's
happening um i don't know
it's it's like it's it's yeah yeah so
oh
so apparently there's something going on
there are some friendly neighborhood
cops who are going to be swinging by and
checking everything out for us
and hopefully everything will be good so
this is a text message i think they got
saying that something suspicious is
happening here they're going to come and
check and make sure everything's okay so
it's basically a swatting again
basically yeah so but we got our are we
got our security guy here he's going to
meet them cool yeah so we we've uh
it's a good thing we have guns
make up guns yeah i have a i have a
katana behind me and it's a good thing
we have security and a good thing that
we have a relationship with the local
police that's right so
so this is number nine i think we're the
with the bomb squad card i know we're
really close to that free yogurt yeah
really close to a free yoga anyway sorry
for uh ditching i had to step out oh no
no i mean it happens i assumed it's
serious if it's if it's gonna be
happening so but but what are they
coming in or what um i think they're
just gonna sleep they're gonna check out
make sure everything's good i'm sure
everything's fine there's been no
nothing suspicious actually going we
know what the message was that was sent
or something yeah so wow yeah so
yeah i i can't say too much about what
we've done for security
but i would think i would say we're
actually well above secure at this point
i'm not super worried about this stuff
yeah it's just it can be disruptive i
guess so there you go everybody thanks
for hanging out it just ha ha ha ha ha
ha ha well actually i i kind of feel
like this sounds a little bit more than
a than a swatting you know what i mean
yeah so this is a little
interesting a little more casual i want
to hear more details on it because i
guess it was a text message that was
sent and i'm not sure a text to who yeah
i'll say who's getting a text message
well look look guys yeah no worries
considering what just happened in
maryland we are like we're about what 45
minutes away from where that guy showed
up at kavanaugh's he flew from
california with weapons planning to
kidnap and assassinate brett kavanaugh
i can't say i'm surprised we're not that
far away so there's creepy weirdos
but so let's talk about this there's
also reports of protests happening
outside of kavanaugh's place right now
yeah i know it's crazy
here's the thing though really all this
boils down
to everybody talks about it being
you know a gun issue it's not a gun
issue i think joe rogan probably said it
best you know we have a mental health
issue described you know
um
kind of couched into a gun issue
disguised as a gun issue now yeah sure
having a mental health issue describe
disguise as a gun issue is a problem
however really this is a value of human
life issue we no longer value someone
else as ha as just a human being you
have value just because i believe you're
creating the image of god so for me you
have value just in that alone we may
disagree fundamentally on a lot of
social issues and maybe even religious
maybe moral issues however you still
have value as a human being and most
people don't have that anymore that's
right part of the desperation of 1928
that i brought up early weimar germany
late weimar germany early nazi germany
when they started to dehumanize other
people probably because they were
wealthy and that they didn't the people
that were desperate weren't wealthy
anymore and they were they were hating
on the wealth and so
desperation breeds you know desperate
actions like i need that food why do you
get that food why were you born into
family that can have food when i right
but for a long time in america
i think that we got to a point where it
wasn't so much that we were we maybe
were going that way but it wasn't so
much that we were needing food
it was that i liked the jordans that you
had
and that's a different value system
altogether as a society you know for us
to be wrapped around that kind of stuff
that's a problem because i think that's
where we start not valuing a human being
anymore
and i think that's a very dangerous path
for us to go down
you're talking about like material yeah
well and it's not even materialism it's
just everything's so superficial you're
not caring about a person and so we have
to get back to the point as a society
because i believe i firmly believe
that americans when we're united we're
unstoppable we've shown that over and
over again we showed it after 9 11 we
showed it in world war one and world war
ii we showed it over and over again
but we've got to get to a point and i
hate that it takes tragedy for it to
happen we have to get to a point where
we are looking at each other no longer
as these different buckets that we put
ourselves in this identity politics but
because you're a human being you have
value to me i was with it back there we
were talking i was talking about uh
humans like in crowds and what what do
the birds think of us when they fly
overhead and look at us like at a rock
concert with 20 000 people all moving in
unison and they were like
uh my girlfriend was telling me like
they must think we are the most
terrifying species on earth because when
we form when formation occurs and we
come together
it's
insanely unstoppable like the power of
the human being right
and
i for better or worse i think of the
nazi the crowds out when hitler's giving
a speech and you see ten thousand nazis
all like marching in secession like it
can be horribly manipulated but also
but because you use it to inspire yeah
and i think that's that's my hope my
people talk about oh you're gonna be a
politician like my my prayer honestly is
i never become a politician my my prayer
is i become a statesman someone who
focuses on the next generation a
politician only focuses on maintaining
power they focus on the next election
cycle a statesman is only focusing on
the next generation and we have to think
long term like that what is this going
to do for the next generation of people
if we start thinking like that again i
think that provides hope what are your
what are your tactics like humanization
tactics when you when you when you
personally seek to humanize you know
crowds or people you disagree with so a
lot of it comes back down to my faith it
really does you know and and i
understand that people are searching for
things um and i think a lot of times we
we misunderstand what we're searching
for but understanding and valuing a
person just because they have value
because they're creating the image of
god to me that's that's such a great way
for me to be able to relate to somebody
because i can cut through all the other
stuff if we disagree i don't care what
it is
abortion police defunding the police we
call it whatever it is second amendment
i can still value you as a person and
that is very important for us to get to
when we were at war oh do you want to no
i was just finished that way when you
were in the middle east and did did that
happen with the enemy combatants was
there a sense of humanization there or
did you have to just
pretend like it wasn't there or what was
that like a little bit of both honestly
going i remember going over the first
time um it was a very difficult thing
for me to process
um because if what i believe is true and
i believe it is you know as far as my
faith um then
i believe that every single person over
there that their life ended they were
separated from a god who loves them
forever so that was a very difficult
thing for me to process and get to a
spot to where i was okay with but once
you're over there and you're operating
you're simply you're performing
with the operation you're protecting
your brother beside you it's a
completely different thing altogether
so do you think that social media has
played like the biggest role in
dehumanizing other people oh yeah it's
so easy to stay behind a keyboard and
scream and shout at each other and you
know type in all caps if you're really
mad but it's but it but it translates
into the real world in ways that many of
us didn't think were gonna happen we
kept saying twitter wasn't real life
right but then that hatred people feel
they bring to the real world you're
right there's this video we can't show
it in full but it's uh went up at 8 12
secret service takedown of a protester
during potus motorcade from fox la this
is one of the craziest videos i've seen
i don't know if it's actually a secret
service takedown there's a woman who
walks into the street
in the middle of the motorcade of the
president bull horning did she get there
and the cops run up and slam her to the
ground and she attacks the cops well
that's dumb
i mean dumb yeah crazy yeah it's like
people are turning into zombies
that's the thing and that's my thing
even with the mass shootings and stuff
like that is you know these people want
to be memorialized forever
even if it's for something bad they want
to be known at this time and the
corporate media according to many
scientific studies now actually promotes
and inspires these mass shootings
because of the way that they cover these
events the way that they show the
picture of the individual than they the
way that they make him infamous the way
that they talk about the manifesto the
details that they give about them this
essentially creates more mass killers
there's a reason uh when someone runs
onto a stadium floor during a sports
ball game that that the
the the cameras don't don't point to him
because they know it's going to inspire
other people to do so the same thing
happens with mass shooters so if we
really wanted to stop it we would be
covering this differently but
they don't msnbc and all these other
corporate media organizations are
literally creating copycat killers uh i
agree and spurring on similar situations
this is why buffalo was so close to the
situation in texas and there might be
even another one with how they've been
reporting on the texas situation with
all you have to do is again stop
focusing on this monster start focusing
on the victims and you would not only
shift the narrative but you would stop
future shootings and mass murderers you
actually start humanizing exactly
absolutely and that's that's what the
corporate media should be doing if they
really wanted to to to stop all these
you know very violent events they would
stop promoting these violent murderers
and giving them the attention that they
want well they don't want to stop them
they want to click but honestly i
actually think that it's you would get
better ratings if you simply focused on
the emotion of it
on the fact that you focus on the
victims i think you get a lot more
engagement from people but instead they
focus on the opposite you were also
saying how it's like people want to be
hurt this is their way of being heard or
seen and i wonder if if someone is
arrested for an attempted mass shooting
or mass shooting maybe but they're still
alive if we should
interview them and let them speak to be
heard because no then
then more people will do it but you'll
also see that on tv but you can see how
crazy it is as well if we hide it then
it's like you call them a monster for
what they are like the people who do
these shootings are monsters yes but
giving them attention means more crazy
people don't name them yeah don't even
name them don't show them that's not it
that's not it let me tell you guys a
story i love this story it's about 11
years ago i'm hanging out i was in
virginia actually
and uh 4chan had an operation called
operation king kong that's all it was
they were watching earth cam which is
live streams around the world
someone pulled up times square and they
said can we use the collective power of
the internet to knock over this street
cone
in the times square camera next to i
think it was tg tgif was a little street
cone and they said okay we've got the
meme up we've got the page up
let's knock it over
people kept trying crazy things someone
ordered a pizza and told the pizza guide
and the pizza guy's like i don't know
what's going on you see the guy in the
bike ride up with the pizza everyone's
spamming like crazy in the in the thread
like he's gonna do it he's gonna no he
left then finally at the end of the day
some some people are walking by some
young guys and then all of a sudden they
walk they walk past it stop
walk backwards like rewinding and then
knock the cone over and then wave to the
camera and everybody's cheering saying
like we did it
then
a woman walks by picks the cone up pulls
a crown out of her purse and puts it on
top of the cone because it was operation
king cone
the point is
people are just trying to move the
needle in any way possible these are
people who are bored they're lonely they
feel like they don't matter at all
anything that gets them any kind of
acknowledgement it doesn't need to be
their name it needs to be the fact that
we talked about the tragedy period is
what they want and they get it even if
you don't show them
they sit back and they watch afterwards
saying all of this because of me
i don't know how you stopped it
i think what we need is i'll tell you
the simple answer is we need dads yep a
lot of the i think the family the common
profile is no dad right yeah ssris as
well heavy yes particularly in many of
these particular cases uh self-harm
self-abuse um mental health issues also
a very big one um and but how much of
that stems from the family unit too yeah
absolutely we've seen it live in the
family university decades exactly and
the pharmaceuticals is no joke sure i
don't know how do you quantify it though
how do you know how much damage adderall
is doing to 13 year olds right how can
you i'm asking a genuine question can't
i mean you've got to look at how much
the the use of it's gone up i mean it's
through the roof from what it used to be
so you're having everybody and it's i
think it's partially parents too you
know we as parents we got to make sure
we have to be much more hesitant to um
put our kids on stuff that we don't
understand
you know even even vaccines for crying
out loud i mean so and the reason i say
that so for my son my oldest son um you
know i got him a flu shot this was a few
years back and i mean he had a small
seizure after the flu shot this was long
before you know coveted and everything
else and so it made us go cool we're
going to have a pause on that for a
while till we figure out what's going on
but make sure crazy conspiracy theorists
yeah well it is what it is i'm gonna do
everything i have to do to protect my
kids i mean we had the the drummer from
uh former drummer from the offspring
right he had guillain-barre syndrome so
they were like you we don't think you
should get this vaccine he got kicked
out of the band for it right they were
like oh sorry we can't work with you
it's like you'd think 17 years would
earn you some loyalty but some people
are just they don't care about that
stuff no yeah when a kid's on
amphetamines you'd be like yeah i'm not
going to get my kid amphetamines but
then all of a sudden it's like oh pfizer
and my doctor said it was okay now i
guess i'll give my kid in like we're
just getting out betterly what do we do
because that's where my head goes now
right with remove some of the
protections from some of these companies
that they're protected they can do
anything they want to do without any
kind of recourse no liability same thing
with that same thing with your facebook
and twitter and everything else me as an
individual i can't sue them
you know but we should be able to yeah
you get hurt you you know it doesn't
matter if your job forced you to do this
right if if the media told you to do
this if the government told you to do
this if your doctor told you to do this
you get hurt you're the one who's going
to be responsible paying for your own
medical bills no one else is going to be
covering or helping you in in any way
shape or form so so you know biden likes
to talk about how the gun industry is
unaccountable not liable
only industry yeah the only industry
well that's not the case here obviously
with all the information that we have in
front of they have more accountability
than probably any other industry right
now i have never understood why the big
pharmacy
the big pharmaceutical you call them a
mafia i've never understood why these
people who literally make things that
you inject into your body and absorb
into your bloodstream have zero
accountability what is going on there i
think it's because they feel like if
something does go wrong which it's bound
to eventually then they'll get sued into
oblivion and then they can no longer
function and the value of
pharmaceuticals is that modern
medicine's a miracle absolutely the
problem is it's the business of medicine
that
they're incentivized to have people be
ill so that they buy their medicine like
if the fire department was incentivized
to put out fires and they got paid more
for every fire they put we have to
evacuate the building you better believe
that uh you'd see a lot more fires you
guys i love you
i think we're gonna leave the keep the
live stream going but we have to
evacuate the boat right all right we'll
be right there from the stream we'll
just stay up as it is please stay tuned
and just please keep watching in case
something happens but we have to be
comfortable while we're on break go to
tommy
we're being told we need to evacuate the
building so keep keep watching keep the
stream up and uh can you do the wide
shot yeah all right
maybe maybe you'll get to watch
something happen i don't know we have to
get out of the building
all right bye guys
we'll be back
okay
now
here
uh
i'm so tired
i'm so tired
i'm so tired
is it working we're streaming
i'm so tired i have one button in my
control panel and it's my face
lydia has all the other buttons
i'm so tired oh my gosh that was fun how
you guys doing anyway
where's tommy
i don't know we owe tommy another show
yeah tommy's uh we owe you another show
man i had to explain graphing to a few
of those guys so we took a little longer
that's right well yeah so what happened
was turns out very obvious an immediate
false alarm and then ian immediately
started explaining graffiti and we all
just got wrapped up for three hours
hexagonally lattice carbon looks like a
honeycomb oh my gosh
all right
okay
that's fine that's great
so we're gonna do uh two hours now right
this is the big payoff you guys also
shout
out to everyone in the chat room they
were very entertaining
and they were keeping up sharecast irl
you guys had a big shapiro point about
the doorknob
uh you know what the craziest thing was
when we were outside right and cops are
in the suite we just kept hearing coffee
brand coffee
and i was like
looking around and then i open the chat
and all i see is chet's coffee brand
coffee i'm like what's happening
quartering
he gave us 400 bucks more than that
thank you shout out to coffee brand
coffee is that coffee brand coffee.com i
have no idea let's find out i was like
my mood was like on a scale of one to
ten one being like
i just wanna just like just lay me down
in the bed and close my eyes i don't
want to think about this anymore and
then the the the so
i was i was being kind of vague in the
tweets but i'll explain a little bit the
the
supervisor cop walks over and then i was
just like immediately at ten i'm like
yes
it's over
so basically credible threat that's it
that's all yeah better safe than sorry
yep
so you know normally
let me clarify a few things for
everybody
my lord it's past midnight so late i
keep seeing people be like
i don't i can't believe this is real
like how does it keep happening
certainly the police realize it's not
happening anymore okay
did you watch the cops walk in the room
i can't believe people are like okay the
thing is this is not this is not
actually happening the cops walked in
the room
and for one we can't show everything
that's happening for security reasons we
can't just film all these squad cars and
vehicles
and protocols and there's operational
security as well that we wanted when the
bomb robot came out they told us
absolutely no filming is allowed of
course not
uh
now i will say chicken city has a live
audio stream
on the property all the time
so
you can always you know people were
tuning in to that
but um what was i gonna say oh yeah hot
chicken action that's what you're doing
yeah hot chicken actually there's a rat
snake now attacking oh yeah it's eating
the eggs you guys party at a different
level around here i'll give you that
wild wildlife
i want to explain something
every single threat results in a police
response that's right every single one
and we get and people are like why don't
the cops realize it's fake it's because
they have to respond for that reason
when people do swattings their goal is
to shock the system to the point where
the police don't care anymore but that's
not how it works these days
when you get swatted the cops show up in
full force
now we have multiple security i can't
i'm not gonna explain we we have armed
guards i won't go into great detail
about that and so now when we get
swatted there's a security protocol
unfortunately for us
you know because we've had other issues
and we we know we've got security we
know how to handle it this time it was
credible
and considering what happened in
what happened in uh chevy chase with
brett kavanaugh yeah which just happened
today some guy came out with zip ties
and weapons
when
this time when it happened when we got
word that something was going on i was
just like oh whatever like you know
lydia jumped up and i'm like oh is this
thing happening whatever we have guards
for this we have protocol for this and
then i started getting some messages
and then the key information as to what
the issue was
contained uh
it was credible
i will say being a special operator your
security is pretty good yeah the issue
is that uh i i don't i can't give away i
can't give out too much details to
explain how this went down because
obviously people try to exploit it but
we had a credible threat and so that's
why you see me get up and leave the room
we assess the situation then i came back
we have to get out
and then uh
i was a little bit vague about it and
i'm not going to give away too much
about the the type of units that were
dispatched but they were specialists
they were not just beat cops and uh we
had to we you know we had a variety of
different branches come out to take care
of the credible threat
and uh everyone's fine everything's safe
it's late i'm tired so as i was saying
the pharmaceutical industry
the federal reserve
and the intelligence agencies i want to
do that again that's that's overtime
yeah that's definitely over so tomorrow
we're going to have tommy back on the
show that's right because that was it
totally brutal man i apologize for you
getting dragged off that's all right now
we got to hang out and uh have some good
conversations we saved a crawfish yeah
we did we did yeah yeah there's worse uh
times or time to spend your life so i
mean we're good you know it made me
think of security in general because i
think a lot of american people at least
i was i lived with like i don't it never
crossed my mind we had the cops
everything was taken care of civil
society but it's not really naturally
like that you really got to take care of
your your own you know so well you do i
mean that's the reality i mean i think
everything i'm sure we'll talk more
about it later but i mean the reality is
i mean look over the last you know few
weeks the things have happened you you
are responsible take care of yourself
for sure shout out to the police man you
guys rock yeah so amazing dudes amazing
people we have uh
in the any analytics 455 000 total
viewers since the show started
and
but most of it is an empty empty room
i i am so amused that uh the empty room
was more interesting than we were i was
a little um yeah the views went up i
know someone's like oh my gosh we're
like wait a minute meditation everyone
was saying that this was better than cnn
so yeah i should have left the website
up at least people would even check out
the website
so whatever music next time yeah so
here's how it goes down we have a
security issue we increase our security
to adapt to it yep next time the
security issue happens it has no effect
that's how basically things were going
until the bomb squad ended up showing up
the last time
and then we adapted our security and
we've solved all these problems and most
of these adaptations are kind of like
really basic simple things that don't
really matter that much it's like oh you
know if we just like do this than that
like there's no big deal
uh
this time
it's credible i don't think we have to
worry about it like it's just
i don't know you got to be better it's
better safe than sorry that always in
times like that you know i mean no
matter what no matter how many times
that happens it's definitely better to
be safe than sorry this you know it's
since january we've had uh eight other
swattings and then one one instance of
the bomb squad coming out
but they're so obviously bunk garbage
right so that we just we adapted our
security model and it's there's no issue
some people are saying like they don't
understand why this hasn't happened to
ben shapiro uh the daily wire they oh
yeah they have a lot of money you know
they have a lot of money they have and
it's crazy i don't want i don't want to
say too much but uh every every every
people with more experience than us know
how to take care of this
and and and better than we've we've been
able to so it's really that simple i
think the show's young
we had tremendous and rapid growth over
the past year or so
now we're building that security
protocol so that these things don't
happen
well the other thing too is i personally
didn't expect to be at this level of
like influence and i don't view us as
being extremists or anything all we do
is talk about the news and current
events and for some reason so
unbelievably inflammatory to people they
think they need to make threats against
us i don't get it i think it just comes
with the the territory in the
entertainment industry a lot of it is
security based like you look at
hollywood and the way they built like
paramount studios it's just a walled com
you can't even get right in without yeah
we we yeah
we got some uh we've had issues people
know about them it's crazy there was a
when we lived in the south south jersey
area there was a really famous youtuber
who lived a few blocks away
literally no security at all it was just
like a residential house and he's got
like a expensive car in his driveway and
i'm just like
millions of subscribers yeah anyway it's
12 22. so i don't think uh also youtube
crashed and deleted all the super chats
you know whatever oh here i can just i
can remember one it's jeremy hambly
saying to buy his coffee
i could go for some coffee brand coffee
this morning because i got to wake up at
7 00 a.m oh good morning everyone it's
12 23 where i'm at yeah it was funny so
when the cop walks up to me and he's
like going over the report he's like
it's now friday
and i was like no it isn't
happy
thursday you're right yeah that's funny
so all right tommy do you want to shout
anything out no just go ahead check out
well it's the middle night now but check
out the website tommy altman.com i
appreciate you guys seriously i really
do think that this is the future of news
i think uh corporate news is dead and
this is what's being birthed out of it
hey listen if if uh if this is what came
out of cove it alone then i think maybe
it was worth it all so that's great this
is this has been the change you know
longer form podcasts and everything so
uh i will say yeah we're definitely not
able to get a members only show up
tonight so i apologize for that but
we're gonna have tommy back tomorrow so
we can we can have a a another shot at
this and uh
smash the like button subscribe share
the show whatever
what a fun night huh you can follow the
show at tim cast irl follow us on
instagram we have clips you can follow
me personally on on instagram where i
basically i don't know i just post
stupid memes or something and tweets or
something stuff like that i'm really
tired
luke i like doing that thanks for coming
on i'm excited for the conversation
tomorrow uh luke uncensored.com is my
website hope to see some of you guys
there ian uh yeah hug your friends man
and get some rest be kind be cool catch
you guys later yeah it was kind of fun
to get outside this evening because i
never get to get out this time of night
we saw crawfish we saw a bunch of
lightning bugs which i always love you
guys can follow me on twitter and
mines.com at sourpatchlids as well as
sour patch lids dot me
yeah let's see uh
we'll uh we'll have a lot to talk about
tomorrow for sure and we're all rested
up and
you know it was a crazy day with what
you know what uh what what happened what
with all that happened with the supreme
court justice and then just this
happening here is just like ugh
i'm going to make me a hot cocoa with
some whipped cream
thanks for hanging out everybody for the
three hours only to come back and get a
quick like five minute update but we'll
be back tomorrow of course i'll be back
at 10am at
youtube.comcastnews i'll have a segment
up there i don't know what i'll talk
about maybe it'll be news maybe i'll
just talk about life because this
stuff's crazy and um
we'll see you all then
you